yeah at which point what what what is
the cut-off for like shorts well it
depends how tall you are i'm
self-conscious you are it depends on
where you are as well some guys say
anything below six foot you're a dwarf
yeah
but then again it's like who says that
i say
it depends well i think the definition
of short is dependent on like your point
of reference right also the country that
you're in right yes if you're from
netherlands then everyone here is short
yeah i feel like an average size human
being in the uk and then i move to like
thailand and like the toilets come up to
my shins
that's that's like the biggest like
indicator of when i go to like thailand
i can't remember
i think japan is like kind of the same
where i go into the public toilets and
normally like it goes up to like my
knees yeah but then the toilets there go
up to my shins and i'm just like what is
this what is this country yeah but like
there's some japanese high school kids
that are [ __ ] massive yeah yeah i've
noticed walk on the train they'll be
like six foot five and i'm like oh my
god i've kind of noticed that they're
like i feel
that when i first moved here or even
earlier than that
everyone around me was shorter than me
but nowadays like as you said there are
like seven feet tall high school kids
and it's like what happened the entire
country just had like a growth
because because i remember i remember
that was anecdotal but yeah no it's
totally anecdotal but like i remember
one point when i was in high school
because i basically i reckon i stopped
growing around like 16 17. i'm still
growing copium i'm still are you no no
i'm not
i i personally stopped going in around
like 16 17. right so right before i
graduated high school and i remember
there was one time where i was on an
absolutely packed train in tokyo and i i
i was like a [ __ ] q-tip in a field of
like cotton swabs like i was just it was
just me and then it's just like a sea of
heads but nowadays i'm just like i get
in a packed train and i'm like everyone
around me is the same height as me like
what happened
why am i baiting is everyone like
i thought i was the only one
who thought he was built different
the exact same as everyone else i was
like i'm exclusively in the six foot
club now everyone is in the six foot
club
well
[Music]
it's surprising that we've taken this
many photos and we still get the same we
get we still get the same three comments
every [ __ ] time asians are taller
than white people no i didn't expect
conor to be the shortest which connor
connor's not a short guy god is not
short that's the thing you're not a
short dude you know you're not sure
incredible meme right now you guys are
like happy i'm like the [ __ ] pain
yeah
i'm not sure
but
i am tiny on this earth well yeah i mean
every time i go to the netherlands i'm
like oh i am literally vertically
challenged right now yeah compared to
everyone else but in japan it's like you
know you meet people who are like three
feet tall and they're living their lives
normally so i'm like
good on you i guess me
like why are you living
is it tough is
[Laughter]
how was hard mode
how's hard mode going
i'm just
kidding my girlfriend is literally the
shortest person i know so yeah i don't
know i don't give a [ __ ] about height i
don't know i think i think it's all
those things that people really care
about and when they do i'm like why i've
been people who are like i will only
date someone unless they're like that's
the common thing right yeah yeah right
i'm like why
why though
like what are the privileges of being
taller than a certain positive
preference right you might like really i
know guys who love taller women than
them they love women that are told them
i get that nothing against that but like
i guess it's the wording right yeah some
girls just
when they when they're worded i i can
understand why it hurts some of those
guys out there that are like i just
wanted a break man
and then i just not six foot and i'm
like it's all right man it's all right
don't worry about it don't worry i don't
get like why is it just that cut off you
know it's just i don't know it's it's
it's always weird to me i'm yet to meet
a woman who was like man i want a man
who's at least four feet tall just every
man be like
thank you
thank you inclusive
i don't know why i think six foot sounds
nice
what about like 175 centimeters or
something at the same range 180
centimeters that's
i don't know it's around the same right
what's what's six foot again 180 i think
i'm exactly six foot so whatever i am
that's not a new standard in metric
joey's like i just made him yeah i
literally i was like just scraped by
there was a god i grew two millimeters
last year and i just scraped by what
i wanted i'm not even
[Laughter]
looking mighty short right now joe
you're kind of looking marty short right
now it's technically 182.8 yeah okay
hold on i know what i am in centimeters
let me let me ask you it's okay it'll
make your dick look bigger hey hey siri
hey sir [ __ ] siri wake up hey siri
what's a hundred and eighty one point
two centimeters in feeding in two throw
in the point two how desperate shut up
i'm desperate shut up
she picked up all that
the answer is
181 centimeters in feet and inches
put it put it up against 81 centimeters
five point nine four which that's what
five eleven
right it's it's not five foot nine
inches it's five point nine four feet
which is five
which means it's five eleven how many
feet how many inches
but it's but it's not uh it's not six
but it's not six though that's all that
matters that's the important thing yeah
it's not six which means you must be six
yeah
yeah yeah he's the chat how does it feel
if you're a real chad i just can't ask a
real chat
i thought i thought you were a brother
to me i thought i was gay
you could have lied this whole time i
couldn't i could have just said 183 just
to make myself feel you could have spent
this whole time lying but now you've
now you've outed yourselves not being
confirmed six foot yeah it's all right i
don't know i like my height it's a
comfortable high i see like people
taller than me and
like i'm at the height where there are
some things especially in japan where it
just gets a bit inconvenient right like
i like some some some buildings are like
i need to like you know just bob my head
down a little bit i can't imagine what
it's like for someone who's like six
five or something yeah like trying to
live in japan could you imagine having a
duck down every time you go into a train
remember that toilet we went into in
that one bar
we found this toilet in this bar and i
posted a video to twitter but like it
was like uh
a closet it was like this tiny little
door opened and you had to no joke like
duck down to like maybe four foot yeah
it was like the it was like [ __ ]
harry's room in [ __ ] philosophy yeah
yeah yeah it was crazy it said toilet on
the wall and i thought the [ __ ] it looks
like some kind of like like some kind of
old 1800s charcoal storage room yeah it
was like it was it was literally like
out of snow white and i said seven
dwarfs
that was just like hobbiton [ __ ]
i don't understand because the room
wasn't that small the room was quite big
it wasn't but the door was comically
small but i like that that was wow
actually you feel like a hobbit i don't
know it just it just looks cool well i
guess it looks unusual we're talking
about it now it was it was like the bar
at uh in nissiko remember the one where
where it was like the the fridge door to
get in and yeah yeah everyone had to
duck down to get into it
that was cool that was cool there's
something about like having a crawl to
just take a [ __ ] this is like shawshank
redemption i don't know it kind of made
me feel like
i don't know it wasn't that small it was
pretty i remember i had to like really
it wasn't a hole like you're like this
like get in like yeah and then i could
get in like i thought that was just like
really small i don't know i thought it
was like is there no regulations around
door sizes in japan no apparently not
i'm sure in the uk we have some like
kind of rule that's like
why would there be why would there be
just for like you know because and maybe
get to the point where you're like all
right to get to the toilet you have to
climb through the vent by the way this
is a mission impossible themed cafe and
it's like ah well it depends what do you
constitute as a door yeah exactly
is it like a cupboard
i felt like it was they were like
stretching the definition of a door yeah
the same way like you know if i were to
uh
open my no i don't know
when i open the fridge no that's a fresh
one
it's a fridge door it was about the same
height as a fridge door yeah yeah i
would say so as well it was not like a
small fridge it was just impressive i
was like okay
why not just like knock a bit of the
wall down and make a bigger door like
does it i could get what they're going
for they're just going for like a unique
i don't think it would go in the bar to
be fair the bar itself was pretty small
it was like a would you describe it like
a diner
like like a diner kind of
there was one there was one bar top and
then there was like two or three maybe
like two like three seater like bar tops
but it looked like the classic diner
seats oh yeah yeah like the black and
white was just like some random bar
because we were finding a place that was
open yeah yeah i don't know why the
toilet fit into the theme there was
nothing to indicate that i would
it was like a hobbit theme or anything
it's really strange but you find us in
japan occasionally just random places
with like the weirdest toilets or doors
yeah there's a there's an izakaya in
shibuya that i go to a few times where
the entrance to it is basically the
toilet door yeah wait it's maybe up to
like here for me oh my god yeah on this
on the street mind you on the main
street what yeah so people who walk in
you just see people [ __ ]
get in on the main road it's so weird
yeah you do see some strange toilets in
japan i remember like
it's sometimes it's just a strange
layout because i remember that one
toilet
uh i think you also tweeted this one out
as well which is i think we were like
having dinner with people from netflix
or something and there was this toilet
in there that was just in the corner and
the lighting was like so ominous that it
felt like you were approaching a jojo
stand yeah
it was like it was like it was like
diagonal yeah it was like diagonal in
this room it was just just leading to
this one toilet and all the lighting was
just behind this one that hit this one
toilet seat yeah
it's like the toilet of the promised
land it's like
japan has that because i feel like the
restaurant comes first then whatever the
[ __ ] they can fit the toilet in they do
it i mean not that we can really talk we
have a [ __ ] toilet over
there
yeah
but i know that there's like um
oh [ __ ] what was it [ __ ]
brain i got my
brain
brain brain commit suicide i forgot i
was going to say it
ah god